hi this is presh talwalkar
this puzzle has gone viral on facebook
and is generating a lot of discussion
can you solve it
if teresa's daughter is my daughter's
mother
then what is my relationship to theresa
am i her grandmother
her mother
her daughter
her granddaughter
or i am theresa
give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution
so i'd like to think about this problem
in terms of the family
tree teresa has a daughter
and i have a daughter
and that daughter of teresa is the
mother of that daughter
so i need to figure out my relationship
to teresa and is going to be at the same
level as the daughter or one level below
teresa
so i am theresa cannot be the answer
because that's at the same level as
theresa
theresa's mother is one level above and
theresa's grandmother is two levels
above
teresa's granddaughter will be two
levels below teresa so that's also not a
correct answer choice so we can
eliminate all of these answer choices
so intuitively most people come to the
conclusion that it might be that you are
teresa's son-in-law and that could be a
possible answer because it would be at
the same level and it could be the case
that that's the answer but it's not one
of the options so we want to remove
son-in-law since that's not one of our
options
so what we're left with is that your
relationship is that you are teresa's
daughter and this fits in with what
we've deduced so far that you should be
at the same level as teresa's daughter
so that could be the case that you are
theresa's daughter
so we put an equal sign here and we get
rid of that
relation between the daughter so you
actually are the so this is a very
verbose way of saying you are teresa's
daughter
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
written books about math and math
puzzles and their links in the video
description